six years after the original series
ended csi vegas premiered tonight
catching up with some of the original
characters yeah it is a sequel to the
original show and the man who put it all
together grew up right here in the las
vegas valley orco mano live near the
strip with more tonight on what was
really a special night orco
well brian and denise the bright lights
here on the las vegas strip are once
again front and center on csi vegas the
very first episode actually just wrapped
up minutes ago right here on channel 8
and tonight we got to chat with the man
who created the franchise
every case every defendant that was put
away csi comes home with the brand new
cbs tv series csi vegas the original
show also set in las vegas premiered on
october 6 2000. here we are 21 years
later to the date i sat down with
anthony zeiker the creator of the csi
television franchise he grew up in las
vegas and is thrilled to see the city
back in the spotlight it means the world
you know the show completely changed my
life
and changed the whole industry the new
show brings back fan favorite characters
from the original series along with
fresh faces to the franchise a little
bit of the old a lot of the new it's a
great hybrid
zeiker's family and friends gathering
for a csi vegas premiere party wednesday
night at fly pie in henderson the big
treat an advanced screening of the first
episode it's super exciting it brings
back all the memories of how vegas used
to be
full of excitement and full of people
the people are going to be able to
experience all of this and just bring
vegas back syker can't wait to show off
more of las vegas with the series and be
able to share the great city with not
only this city the country and the world
and here's a fun note one of our very
own will be part of the show the
i-team's george knapp will play a news
anchor in a couple of the episodes the
first episode he's in will air on
october 20th reporting live near the las
vegas strip tonight orca mana live local
now